[Music]
10 36 is the time you're watching the
press preview a first look at the front
pages as they arrive time to see what's
making the headlines with the director
of the john smith center at the
university of glasgow kezia dugdale and
the conservative commentator tim
montgomery they will be with us from now
until just before midnight but first
let's run you through the front pages
that we have starting with the metro
that reacts to tonight's conservative
leadership debate and warnings that
rishi sooner and liz trustee's attacks
on each other
could lose the party the next election
according to the guardian tax and
inflation the key discussion points
the ft reports that russian gas supplies
to europe are under threat after moscow
decided to cut the flow to the
north stream pipeline to germinate to
just 20 of capacity
children are still able to buy knives on
the high street with ease according to
an investigation in the mirror
the sun says that the footballer
cristiano ronaldo has flown into
manchester demanding he be able to leave
united
and you will forgive me for not quoting
the headline directly the star blunt in
its assessment of a report which found
that police patrols reduce violent crime
by up to 70 percent
uh just a reminder that by scanning the
qr code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages while you us uh but we are joined
this evening at by kezia dugdale and tim
montgomery lovely to see both of you um
kez here let's start with you shall we
well first and foremost did you actually
manage to watch any of the debate
presumably you were you're tuned into
sky news and couldn't be bothered with
it on the bbc
the beauty of technology neil of course
is you can have more than one channel on
at a time these days so yes of course i
watched the debate and i think in in in
the round it was good television it
wasn't particularly edifying for the
conservative party and labour party
spinners will be sitting tonight cutting
it up into nice slices of content to go
on the attack in the morning but as
you've seen from your own snap ball i'm
not sure it's been particularly decisive
either it looks like people watching the
program certainly regular voters have
called it a score draw that just means
more time for these candidates to attack
each other
tim as we look at the front of the
guardian i mean clearly there are
differences of approach
between the two candidates who would be
prime minister on a number of topics but
tax inflation sorting out the economy
sorting out the cost of living i i mean
there are there is clear blue water
between the two candidates and most of
that
there certainly is and um i think
tonight's debate was again ill-tempered
which surprised me actually because the
previous debates where we've had all of
the candidates involved they didn't go
down well with the public because there
was quite a lot of touchiness between
the candidates and i thought and hoped
as a conservative supporter that both of
them would reign that in tonight but the
reality is of course is that rishi sunak
is well behind his trust in polls of
tory members and i think he needed to
sort of go for the jugular a bit
to catch up and as you say neil it's on
the issue of tax the economy the cost of
living these are the issues i'm sure a
lot of your viewers would rather us
discussing tonight because they are
rather than a tory leadership contest
because it is the cost of living that is
dominating everyone's lives at the
moment and um it was obvious that uh the
tory leadership candidates would focus
on those two issues and liz trusses
promise of immediate tax cuts so she
says on day one of her becoming prime
minister should she win has really
become the issue so far in this uh in
this race i mean kesley we will have
plenty of time to discuss the policies
over the of the the next hour and a half
but i mean the guardian article puts it
itself this has gotten to be incredibly
acrimonious on the record criticism
singling out rishi sunax wealth and
wardrobe list trust has faced claims of
being economically illiterate and a
former brexit remainer if you can work
out what that is i mean it's only going
to get worse
yes and arguably that was the mild stuff
and when we had a quote from rishi sunak
tonight saying that liz truss's economic
plans would push millions into misery
and cost the conservatives the next
party election as criticism goes it
doesn't get much harsher than that and
it's also a gift to the labour party so
if the main issue of this election
contest and in the political debate to
come is cost of living and the dividing
line is around cost of living with two
polar opposites opinions on what needs
to happen now it's very difficult to see
how the conservative party is going to
be able to come through this contest
with any degree of unity amongst itself
it's very very difficult and it's not a
pretty picture for the party tonight tim
i just saw you there you were nodding
along there when kezia said that this is
a this is a gift for the labour party
but if the acrimony continues i mean
what is it that the conservative
selector are actually looking for rishi
sunak seems to be selling himself as
being absolutely honest uh with the
conservative party membership at liz
trusts
i don't know perhaps clothing herself in
some of the boosterism that proved to be
pretty effective for boris johnson
yeah i i think the problem for rishi
sunak is is that of course he's been
chancellor
for the last few years and while his
time as chancellor started incredibly
well there'll be many people who remain
grateful for the innovative furlough
scheme
that help many families and help britain
through the pandemic
i think since then though he's become
less
much less sure-footed and as was clear
in the debate uh britain is the only
major economy in the world to have put
up taxes during a cost of living crisis
and that he of course was chancellor
during that period he put up those taxes
and this really isn't where most
conservative members think the party
should be it's not where kezia's party
the labour party is either the labour
party have said it was the wrong thing
to put up taxes and not just to put up
taxes generally you know you could have
put taxes on assets for example which
would perhaps would penalize better off
people more but the tax rise that we've
all been experiencing is a rise in
national insurance you know which really
does affect you know you know what the
working families the people in the red
wall who really gave boris johnson his
majority so it is as you say neil it's
been easier for
liz trust who has said that when she was
you know in a cabinet meeting objected
to the rise in national insurance she's
behind the easier position really to
embrace that boosterism of boris and it
looks like rishi sunak is the one stuck
with this very unpopular national
insurance rise around his neck
um kezia we're going to look at um page
six of the daily mirror i mean echoing
the metro front page which says you'll
lose is the next election page six of
the mirror though characterizing uh the
two leadership candidates one is a
hectoring bully and the other is a total
incompetent that's just the daily
mirrors take but i wonder giving your
experience of politics to what extent do
people make their minds up about a
candidate when they see him on events
like tonight as i mentioned you know i
was working at nine o'clock and i'm sure
even my bosses wouldn't like me to
multitask and have a bbc app open on my
phone whilst reading the news but you
know i didn't see him but i have seen
plenty of people describing at mr
sunac's performance tonight as perhaps a
little to troll perhaps a little
hectoring
so i think there's two things to say
about that first of all the academic
evidence suggests that tv debates in
general elections don't make a huge
material difference the first time we
had stevie debates in general elections
was back when nick clegg was around if
you remember and there was the nick-like
phenomenon for a while after that though
the impact of tv debates and general
elections declined quite considerably
that didn't she
change the minds of people who were yet
to make their minds up it didn't move
the dial to any great degree i do think
it's very different though when it comes
to internal party contests like the one
that we're watching just now which
albeit is extremely important because
the winner of this contest will become
the next prime minister of the united
kingdom but what happens in a contest
like this amongst leadership candidates
within a party is that they are seeking
to consolidate the votes they have and
to change the votes that they need to
win and that's why you saw such an
attacking style from rishi suna they
actually couldn't afford to deploy in a
general election campaign you couldn't
go this hard because you'd be perceived
as bullish
and unlikable whereas he has to behave
like this tonight in order to try and
get some of those uh votes back from liz
trust the second really interesting
thing i thought about the debate tonight
was it ended quite positively with both
candidates being quite kind and generous
to each other only for us to turn to
twitter to see the briefing wars begin
and liz trusses spokespeople were
already out
talking about the aggressive
mansplaining of rishi sunak's style
during the during the evening's debate
and also talking about his private
school education
leading him to carry himself with that
confidence and liz trust herself
described herself as perhaps not the
slickest of communicators that had
reminiscence of i'm not flash just
gordon something that gordon brown used
to do in
tv communication exercises like this so
i do think it's different when it comes
to internal party contests and and in
that bit it does matter
briefly tim if we can we just want to
squeeze in the front the front of the
mail and in leadership contests like
this there's an awful lot of what i kind
of tend to call political butchery going
on you know both candidates looking for
red meat to fling their their supporters
way liz truss as the daily mail points
out curbing the unions i mean i suspect
that will play pretty well with large
sections of the conservative membership
i don't think it will just play well
with conservative members i think you
know i've just had to cancel various
plans uh you know to come up to london
on wednesday because of the the the
train strike i live in salisbury um
during the train strike you know i've
sort of ended up an hour and a half
journey became six hours we poured you
know hundreds of millions of pounds into
the rail industry during the pandemic as
a nation only for trained drivers to
sort of train workers to want even more
money from the taxpayer and so i think
actually having some sort of crackdown
on militant trade unism it won't be
popular with the labour party but i
think it will be popular with a lot of
long-suffering commuters and other
people who depend upon our public
services
tim kezia we will be back to you in just
a couple of minutes time but you stay
right where you are after the break we
will be once again discussing northern
ireland's original first minister david
trimble and indeed his legacy after this
[Music]
welcome back to the press preview as you
can see kezia doug dalton montgomery is
still with us um and tim let's let's
turn to you first and we return to the
front page of the guardian of course
a lot of the front page furniture taken
up by other stories but you would have
been surprised if your major national
newspaper did not mention the passing
of lord trimble
a huge figure um in our history and
those of us who are old enough to uh
remember the troubles in northern
ireland know that for a large part of
modern british history and there's been
terrible there was terrible violence not
just on the streets of northern ireland
but it um it spilled over into into
britain as well lots of innocent people
lost their lives and it was a huge
conflict
and with all conflicts huge amounts of
compromise need to be made by both sides
and it often takes some of the more
hard-line members of the communities to
bring to make the compromises because
they have the authority david trimble
was someone that at the time of the good
friday agreement really did have the
confidence of the of the unionist um
community and he's able to make the
compromises with sinn fein with the sdlp
that brought peace in northern ireland
and um he was a giant figure he was a
prickly person in many ways he was not
easy to get on with i certainly had a
few arguments with him in recent years
over over various political issues
unrelated to northern ireland but
without him perhaps we wouldn't have had
peace in northern ireland when we did
and so a real giant of our politics and
may he rest in peace he certainly has
earned a good place upstairs for all the
efforts um he made on behalf of the
peace process i mean kezia those of us
who grew up in the west coast of
scotland were perhaps not as directly
involved with events that were taking
place in northern ireland as those who
were living in belfast but we certainly
knew what was going on on just across
the water your reflections on the death
of david trimble
yes well it definitely shaped us and
shaped british politics without question
next year will mark 25 years since the
good friday agreement and i'm involved
in my day job and thinking about some
good ways to remember that particular
achievement achieved specifically by
david trimble and by john hume from the
sdlp who were both then awarded nobel
peace prizes and for their efforts and i
think one thing that you'll see a lot of
in the obituaries that are going to
follow in the coming days is a
recognition of the fact that david
trimble and indeed john hume both
essentially lost their political careers
because of the sacrifices they made in
securing peace there is no better act or
greater act of public service than that
than to do the right thing and to make
those compromises to seek that consensus
that they did that brought peace to
northern ireland so there's there's no
doubt that he was a giant of politics
and it's down to him in a great and
significant part that the peace that we
enjoy that fears so fragile now in
northern ireland is down to his
achievement
i'm a slight change of direction for our
last story i am not a fan of eurovision
i will be getting absolute pelters on my
social media after pointing that out for
about the umpteenth time you i know are
presumably one of the uk's biggest fans
you must be dead excited that eurovision
is coming back to these shores
neil don't tell anyone but i'm with you
i'm afraid i'm another eurovision
skeptic so hopefully kez will rescue our
reputation and protect us on social
media by being enthusiastic for it but
look what i am always enthusiastic about
is having a big event like this in
britain and i'm sorry that because of
the conflict in ukraine that they won't
get to host it they obviously deserve
the opportunity to host it but i'm sure
i think that bbc if we mentioned the bbc
again they're getting a lot of coverage
tonight on scholarships
but the bbc will be able to host it and
i hope there'll be a good thread running
through it i'm sure there will be where
we honor the people of ukraine because
it's a conflict that's still going on
indeed and perhaps has dropped a little
bit too much from the headlines okay
you've got five seconds to tell us why
we're both wrong and eurovision is
brilliant
because eurovision is fundamentally
about politics i'm
at you both
sam rogers in a great video tonight
saying why he's so proud to bring it to
the country and i think that's that's
really good and worth a watch